the nature of mind is a philosophical
essay written in 1980 by Australian
philosopher David Armstrong it's not a
very well-known or a normally important
work but it's a pretty interesting one
addressing a question that people have
been trying to answer for thousands of
years what is the mind when we perceive
and feel and think what's actually going
on in this essay Armstrong tries to
understand the mind in materialist terms
materialism is the notion that
everything is made up of an explainable
by material or physical stuff this
contrasts with the ideas of people like
Rene Descartes whose dualist philosophy
conceived was the mind as a kind of
spiritual substance separate from the
physical world Armstrong is interested
in materialism rather than Judaism
basically because that seems to be what
science records science Armstrong says
seems to be narrowing in on an
explanation of the mind in purely
physical chemical terms and science has
an authority because while it does make
mistakes it can achieve consensus among
experts on controversial matters after
prolonged investigation in other words
it's probably right because science is
really really good at working stuff out
so I'm strong champions science and
therefore materialism as the best hope
we have to understand the mind
Armstrong discusses a materialist theory
of mine called behaviorism which holds
that the mind is not something behind
the behavior of the body it is simply
part of that physical behavior so anger
for example is angry behavior shouting
or stamping or writing in comprehensible
YouTube comments if there's no angry
behavior there's no anger so strict
behaviorism claims that the mind as an
internal personal experience doesn't
really exist there is only behavior this
Armstrong points out is pretty bloody
silly it seems obvious that a person can
say feel one way and behave another
there's something more than just
behavior so Armstrong refers to a
refinement of behaviorism called
dispositional behaviorism which suggests
that mental states are dis
positions towards possible behavior the
idea is explained with an analogy of
glass glass has a disposition towards
shattering if put under pressure
perhaps the mind is similar anger is a
disposition towards behaving angrily
under the right circumstances it may be
expressed even this thought doesn't seem
quite right it seems obvious as anything
is obvious Armstrong says that there is
something actually going on in me that
constitutes my thought anger is more
than just a disposition towards possible
behavior so to form his account of the
mind
Armstrong further modifies dispossession
or behaviorism he suggests that mental
states like anger are actual physical
states of the brain that may or may not
lead to behavior this combines the
Descartes Ian's idea that the mind is
that which is behind and brings about
behavior with a behaviorist idea of
dispositions and most importantly it's
compatible with scientific materialism
so this idea is what Armstrong calls
central state materialism the minds
mental states aren't just dispositions
towards behavior nor are they products
of a dualistic ghost in the machine they
are actual physical states of the brain
Armstrong goes on to address our central
state materialism can explain
consciousness he talks about how the
brain can go on autopilot for example if
you go on a long drive without a break
you might suddenly come to and realize
that while you've stayed on the road
stopped at red lights and operated that
clutch you're completely unaware of
doing so this tuning out shows that as
possible for mental processes to take
place without conscious experience
consciousness then he says is no more
than perception or awareness of the
state of our own mind a self scanning
system in the central nervous system the
mind will happily do its thing whether
we're aware of it or not
consciousness is a simple map paying
attention so to quickly summarize what's
already a pretty quick summary David
Armstrong central state materialism
synthesizes Descartes dualism and
dispositional behaviorism to arrive at
an account of the mind where mental
states are physical states of the brain
which may lead to behavior and
consciousness is a self scanning system
in the central nervous system this is a
philosophy of mind that's compatible
with the experience of consciousness and
with scientific materialism I hope you
enjoyed this video you might like to
subscribe or suggest a topic for future
videos thanks